So, with that says, uh, Mike have a
question. Okay. He's saying, "Hi, Sam
and Alfati. How do I respond to some
Christians who constantly mock other
denominations and say things like,
"Catholics are not saved and these are
cults and so on and so forth." I mean,
it's a question. It's a tough question,
Sam. No, I mean I can give you a
biblical answer, but you're
already
suggesting these are mockers professing
to be Christians, which means no matter
what you show them, what you say to
them, they've made up their mind.
There's no way you can convince them
otherwise. So if that's the case, don't
waste your time with them. Don't involve
yourself with them. Don't fellowship
with them. leave them be and pray the
Holy Spirit will convict them. Because
if they're true Christians, the spirit
will convict them and chase and rebuke
them to be humble and not condemn other
brothers and sisters in Jesus Christ who
are born of the spirit but don't belong
to their denomination. But if they're
open to hearing that there are brothers
and sisters in Jesus Christ in all the
major branches of trinitarian
Christianity, note trinitarian
Christianity, those who go to churches
that do
profess and worship and love the triune
God and believe the Bible's God's
perfect words, there will be true
believers in those branches of
Christianity. doesn't mean everyone who
goes to that church is saved. But there
will be true believers in those branches
and there'll be wolves in sheep's
clothing. That's just a given. But if
they're open enough to hear why they
shouldn't be so quick to condemn others
because they don't belong to their
particular tradition, brother, go to
Mark 9 38-39.
Mark 9. 38-39.
Okay. Sorry. Sorry. There's a brother HC
International. My apologies. When you
quoted John 14:28, I thought you were
trying to refute the deity of Jesus
Christ by quoting another passage that
I've answered millions of times. My
apologies, brother. I just saw John
14:28. My bad. Forgive me. So, if you're
a Trinitarian, welcome, brother. The
Lord Jesus bless you and fill you. But I
just read that comment, so you scared
me. So, you're guilty until proven
innocent in my channel. But go ahead,
read Mark 9:38-39.
All right. Uh Mark
9:38. John said to him, "Teacher, we saw
someone casting out demons in your name,
and we tried to stop him because he was
not following us." But Jesus said, "Do
not stop him, for no one who does a
mighty work in my name will be able soon
afterward to speak evil of me." Did you
see what Jesus said? The disciple says,
"He's not part of us. He's not part of
our group. He's not part of our
denomination." So, we stopped him from
proclaiming your name. And Jesus says,
"Don't do that." Because if he does a
miracle in my name, then he knows who I
am, which shows that he believes in me
and loves me and he trusts in me and
therefore he belongs to me. So, although
he may not belong to your group, he
belongs to
me. So, do not discourage him. Now let's
look at the Luke version. Luke
9:49-50. Luke
9:49-50. The Lucan version.
Luke
9 49-50.
Yeah. All right. So 49 says, "John
answered, Master, we saw someone casting
out demons in your name, and we tried to
stop him because he does not follow with
us. But Jesus said to him, "Do not stop
him. For the one who is not against you
is for you." Wait, wait. The one who's
not against you is what? Is for you. So
again, Jesus, he's not part of our
group, not part of our click, not part
of our
denomination. Do not stop him. He was
not against you, is for you in the sense
that he's not opposing me. He's not
denying me. He's not blaspheing me. He
believes in me, knows who I am. Because
if he didn't believe in me and didn't
know who I was, he wouldn't be using my
name to do miracles as a sign that he's
mine and does trust in me. So if he
trusts in me, he belongs to you even
though he may not be part of your
particular group. Now let me give you
another one. 1 Corinthians 1
10-16. 1 Corinthians 1 to 10-16.
Okay. 1 Corinthians 1:10 to 16.
Okay. Verse 10. I appeal to you brothers
by the name of our Lord Jesus Christ
that all of you agree and that there be
no divisions among you but that you be
united in the same mind and the same
judgment. For it has been reported to me
by Clo Khloe's people that there is
quarreling among you my brothers. What I
mean is that each one of you says I
follow Paul or I follow Apollos or I
follow Cphus or I follow Christ. Is
Christ divided? Was Paul crucified for
you? Or were you baptized in the name of
Paul? I thank God that I baptized none
of you except Chrisus and Gaes so that
no one may say that you were baptized in
my name. I did baptize also the
household of Stfanis. Beyond that I do
not know whether I baptized anyone else.
For Christ did not send me to baptize,
but to preach the gospel, and not with
words of eloquent wisdom, least the
cross of Christ be emptied of its power.
You gave me verse 17 as well. I
appreciate you, brother. Okay, but now
let's take it in a modern example. See,
at the time of Paul, notice, even in the
lifetime of apostles, Christians, open
your ears. At the time of the apostles,
there were divisions among Christians
and they're dividing along
denominational lines. Meaning, hey,
Peter the rock baptized
me. See, I'm better. Paul baptized
you. So, what you find today was true
back then in the lifetime of the
apostles. Even the presence of the
apostles could not guarantee perfect
union among the churches. So why would
you expect in the absence of the
apostles were not physically with us
that today we're going to have perfect
union if they could be divided even in
lifetime of the apostles expect us to be
divided now without this implying we're
not brothers and sisters in Jesus so now
let's take a modern
example the Roman Catholic Church
appeals to Peter as being the rock upon
which the church is built and I agree
with that but they also say and then
Peter appointed the bishop of Rome as a
successor. So now imagine the situation
is the same today. Roman Catholics say
well I belong to Peter. The Coptics say
well we belong to John Mark because
tradition says it was John Mark who
established the church in Egypt. And
then the Assyrian church and he says
well we belong to Bartholomew to Thomas.
So you're doing the same thing that they
were doing back then. When you say I'm
the church of the east, well, you're
basically saying, well, I'm I'm of
Thomas
Bartholomew. When you say I'm the Roman
Catholic church, well, I'm Peter. When
you say you're doing the same thing
today that they were doing at the time
of Paul and Paul says, no, Peter
baptized you, you're still a brother in
Christ. Paul baptized you, you're still
a brother in Christ. Apollos baptized
you. It doesn't matter who led you to
faith, who discipled you, because we're
all one body and we have one head.
Praise God you follow Apollos. Praise
God you follow Paul. Praise God you
follow Peter. Because we are all one
body. We're not different bodies
preaching a different head.
Okay, hope to answer the questions.